some of the people that serve with me on
the House of Representatives even though
they may have Noble intentions they are
useful fools because what they think
that what they're peddling is good for
others no they because they have never
had the experience of being or living in
Cuba or Venezuela go for two weeks to
Havana I always tell them two weeks only
now make it a week with a Cuban family
living with no dollars and waiting to
come to the United States go live with
them for one week and then you tell me
what the beauties of socialism oh no
because we don't really want the the
Cuban or the Venezuelan type of
socialism really so what socialism would
you like right
thank you
all right day three of three in DC
continues I'm still Dave Rubin this is
still the Reuben report and joining me
today is a congresswoman representing
Florida's 27th District which happens to
be my district Maria Salazar yeah
and welcome to District 27. I can't
remember Melting Pot it is indeed I
can't promise you this is going to be a
very combative interview because uh I
told you when you walked in I voted for
you everyone in this room voted for you
thank you yeah you guys are smart people
and we're all pretty thrilled about
what's going on now you live in my
district and I'm in your District uh
we're thrilled obviously with what's
going on in Florida Miami specifically
yes so before we get into the nuts and
bolts of that uh could you just give the
people that that may not know you a
little bit of your history of an
interesting work history and family
history that it frames a lot of your
politics sure of course I was um first
generation Cuban American my parents
came to that City 1960 uh thanks to the
United States that opened up the doors
to uh two million Cubans who were
fleeing probably the most cruel and the
most evil Revolution that the Americas
has seen since the arrival of
Christopher Columbus completely
completely uh a bad situation so I grew
up in Miami I I have an accident because
my parents could not find work like many
other millions of Cubans and we had to
hop from Island to Island and I lived in
Puerto Rico some of the time another
time in Miami uh that's why I speak
Spanish and I can communicate with 72
percent of my district that happens to
be Hispanic descent I may need you to
help me brush up on something of course
because yes everybody down there is cute
yes
but we love the American exceptionality
and I I more and that's why I represent
them proudly
um I went to the University of Miami
after that I started working for
Univision I'm one of the founders of
Spanish television Univision and
Telemundo then I went to Harvard and I
worked hard at 35 years in front of the
camera
paying my rent and after that I decided
to come and serve the country and
believe me this is a lot harder and it
pays a lot less it is highly gratifying
highly gratifying to be able to
represent the American values in the
United States Congress so my guys showed
me right before your your election
history is really interesting because in
2018 you lost by three points then in
2020 you won by three points and then in
2022 you won 15 I had 13 here but I'll
go with 15. and that sort of is
indicative of the directions that
Florida's gone in right well because the
problem is that the word socialism it's
highly scary and every time a democratic
a member of the democratic party
mentions Democratic socialism we run the
other way whether whether you're
registered as independent or as a
Democrat it doesn't matter 30 percent of
democrat registered non-cuban Hispanics
voted for Salazar because we do know
that they promised that paradise and
what you get is hell at the end so
anything that has to do with Socialism
or socialist policies you may have some
social programs that could benefit the
underprivileged but don't give me
socialism and that's why Maria Salazar
is serving the most difficult District
in the State of Florida difficult
meeting where you have where you're 50
50 is not that the you are in a very
highly concentrated Republican District
no no no no this is or even one-third
Democrats one-third Republicans
one-third independent and that does seem
to be shifting though a little bit right
because after this last wave I mean
DeSantis took Miami which uh yes
Miami-Dade County yeah first time in 20
years
a republican Governor why because we are
understanding that this country is
politically speaking is not going the
way we need it to and the pro what
people have to understand is that people
say well because Florida there was a Red
Wave yeah because you have people in
Florida the people who live in Florida
come from either Venezuela or Cuba or
Nicaragua or Central America right or
Worse Los Angeles well okay all right so
that you have a point of reference you
cannot understand what's black if you
have not seen white or vice versa so
once you my parents so black really
black so now when they see why they run
away because they have a point of
reference but unfortunately some of the
members and some of the people that
serve with me on the House of
Representatives even though they may
have Noble intentions they are useful
fools because what they think that what
they're pedaling is good for others no
they because they have never had the
experience of being or living in Cuba or
Venezuela go for two weeks to Havana I
always tell them two weeks only make it
a week with a Cuban family living with
no dollars and waiting to come to the
United States go live with them for one
week and then you tell me what the
beauties of socialism oh no because we
don't really want the the Cuban or the
Venezuelan type of socialism really so
what socialism would you like right they
want that one that's never been put into
practice or that we don't know yeah so
how is it for you going from your
District in Miami which is highly
functional I mean everything I I'm
telling you like I have no complaints I
wish that you're my congresswoman I wish
I could come to you and be like fix a
couple things but it's working our roads
are good our police are fantastic it's
clinging there's no homeless people
there's no drugs on the streets there's
no riots but when you go from that down
in Florida and then you come here where
it's so dysfunctional and so crazy and
just as you said you're talking to
members of Congress who have you know
their ideas come completely backwards
how do you put those two things together
you know I said we speak another
language and I've been trying to I've
been meaning to sit with some of the
members that like Democratic socialism
and I've been wanting to ask them what
is it that you know that I don't I don't
know tell me explain to me what is it
that you see that I don't see because
because Democrats and Democratic
socialists do not have a monopoly on
compassion we are compassionate too
I want to help those or I want to help
the Browns of the African Americans and
those kids that don't have good
schooling because I know that education
is the way out of poverty I want to help
them too but I don't want to I don't
want to atrophy them and just give them
money and money money and and and and
and give them the wrong incentives so I
don't know what to say maybe it's just I
have it in my DNA
and like I said you know we lived it
have you been able to sit down with any
of them for the record
we tried to get AOC here this week we
tried to get Rashida to leave we tried
to get ilhan Omar and we tried for
everybody nobody said yes well I have
specifically gone to talk to the black
caucus because I want the black caucus
to help me defend the afro-cubans in
Cuba who are being beaten and brutalized
by the Cuban police when they go on the
streets and scream Freedom that has been
my ask as help me with the afro-cubans
we're not here to talk about Cuba the
Embargo food no no we're here to talk
about defending the afro-cubans they are
as black as you are I need to you I need
you to help me defend them because they
are my constituents or at least I have
constituents that are their relatives
but I don't get any response I know I do
not understand because if you come to me
to something that is so dear to me as
defending African-American
African-American rights and black lives
matters but you know black lives matter
across the board not only in the United
States in Latin America too and you have
the repressive apparatus in Havana
repressing those people who are who are
afro-cubans and who are screaming and
saying libertad we want free Freedom so
why don't we have the black caucus in
the United States helping them I don't
get it well I think it would expose a
lot of there and I went to them and I
went to three specific members and
they're saying yeah yeah we want to work
with you then let's do it
I'm waiting yeah I sense I sense so
things are working in Florida I had
Governor DeSantis on a couple weeks ago
and I said look obviously I'm a
supporter of his and I and I I know how
great things are in Florida but I was
like all right I gotta ask you one tough
one so let me let me ask you one tough
one too as you've seen this influx of
people into Florida obviously we're
having a house price issue because
they're just 1200 people moving today
it's just this function of success what
can we do about that beyond beyond just
building faster which I know they're
trying to do is there anything else that
can be done because a lot of the
original Floridians are now being priced
out and and I don't want them to pay for
for doing it right well Floridians who
said that do not have the income or the
right income in order to well I've been
talking to the mayor of the city of
Miami and in my district I'm trying to
find tax incentives and tax initiatives
for those wealthy developers to buy land
that it's highly prized at this hour and
be able to to build some Workforce and
some affordable house and that's what
I'm working on there are solutions and
the federal government can help those in
the private sector to make some money
and at the same time serve the community
so that's the way as someone that was
part of the media for a couple decades
yeah you know the media tends not to be
too friendly to some of the ideas we're
talking about here does that surprise
you or is that I'm very just just very
disappointed because I I mean I am a lot
I'm older now and I started in 1983.
1983 uh the American School of
Journalism ruled
you have the Walter cronkites you have
the Peter Jennings you had the um what
was the name of that guy who was doing
Nightline Ted couple you know you you
did not dare these were old school
journalists of course what do you mean
giving your opinion what
that that was not part of the game and
right now I'm not sure what type of
Journalism we have we have commentators
we have Advocates and that is I think
that's confusing uh the public when you
are watching the newscast and you think
that what he or she is saying is facts
and news and its opinion even the fact
that every American basically knows the
name AOC and ilhan Omar and Rashida
Talib and they don't know you right like
at a national world and that even sort
of shows it right of course yeah because
I'm not uh expressing the scary
capitalists well that's right and a
brown girl from the hood yeah
it was an accent what do you make of
what's going on in DC right now I sense
Republicans are kind of feeling pretty
good about things I interviewed speaker
McCarthy yesterday he feels like there's
an agenda to go forward with that makes
sense for people do you feel like
there's really some momentum and things
could change there's momentum at least
we're sending the message and we're
telling the American people
um that we are here to try to fix the
national major economic and social
problems the Border
the Border major issue for 35 years and
no one has dared to to
um make that a priority and I am because
I think I I can't do it we got to seal
the Border we have to seal the border
and put on all the technology that is
out there available to prevent people
from sneaking in and from the drugs and
the arms everything that's illegal
coming and going seal the water and then
after you do that then review the legal
immigration and review what are you
going to do with the 13 million people
who are right now here watching us that
do not have papers what are you going to
do with them I take it you were pretty
thrilled when these illegals come
through Texas or whatever they make it
to Florida and then Governor DeSantis
basically puts him on a bus and sends
them to Delaware or to Martha's Vineyard
it's it's just yeah but that's not
that's not the way if we fix the problem
I'm trying to fix their problem at the
root yes don't let them come in
illegally and if they are then you know
what they're gonna why are they here
give them a legal Visa you know like we
can talk about my dignity program
whenever you want to but we do have to
fix the problem how are we going to fix
it so you know there has to be otherwise
you I mean you keep on having what's
happening it's it's it's it's it's
Unthinkable yeah they're coming in and
they're they don't have work permits so
what how do you think that they're gonna
live how are they going to eat we're
gonna give them a bunch of stuff well
that's not the way to do it either right
what do you mean giving them government
programs I'm not for it I'm just telling
you what the demographics are going to
do yeah let join that you have to work
and how are you going to work I have to
give you a piece of paper that gives you
a permit but at the same time I'm
letting you in if you are not legal so
that's why I'm saying stop this madness
is there are there any Democrats like
when you hear mayorkas basically being
like Oh The Border is not open and yet
we have more border crossings than ever
than ever in this past year it's just
you know when the politicians are saying
you know what's what's the empirical
evidence the empirical evidence is that
we need to solve this problem and like I
said I'm the only Republican member of
Congress that has put together an
initiative it's called the dignity act
and we can review it whenever you want
to and it solves the problem because let
me tell you something we also have a
legal immigration problem what does that
mean that if you want to attract the
Albert Einsteins of the world if you
want to bring the best Minds leaving
Ukraine or Russia or China you need to
give them a Visa for them to come in and
that legal path is not so easy to come
into the United States you know that too
right that's not good for our economy
yeah so Miami though has an incredible
economy right now and we're growing and
obviously mayor Suarez has done an
unbelievable job bringing we I mean
we're basically the tech leader now in
the world has that how has that changed
the way you've thought about your
constituents and you know all of these
new people fitting into all of this well
I think that the system takes care of
itself and you see right now you just
said at the housing market now we have
more shops my constituents are doing
better economically speaking because we
have people like you like you coming in
and consuming the market always finds
its way and and but the only thing I can
tell you is that if you love the system
like we do and District 27 some of my
people the people that are serving you
and your staff may not know English that
well but the English is in their hearts
yeah I'm working on it I mean everyone
that comes in my house they're teaching
me Spanish I'm teaching them English
thank you I I I welcome you to ask them
what do you think about the United
States oh America we love America yes
yes best country you just just you know
no trust me I know it I'm out there with
my landscapers every every week and
we're talking on Earth best country this
country my country just got here two
years ago but they also one of the
things that I found and this is
definitely different than some of the
immigrants in LA and I don't think this
is not it tends to be more Mexican there
where it's more Cuban and Venezuelan yes
uh the the work ethic is unbelievable
these guys are busting their butts we
don't want anyone to give us anything
because if you make it for yourself
which is what I was trying to say to the
underprivileged uh communities I don't
want the Democratic socialists to be
teaching our children that let me give
you no no let me give you the
opportunity for you to earn it yourself
and not take away from you that joy and
the taste that I made it and that I am a
successful human being because look
whether it's a landscaping company
whether it's a car dealership or like me
you know I made it to Congress wow in
one generation and how do you think I
did that because the system gave me the
opportunity I busted my butt working on
television oh Jesus did I but that gave
me the platform for people to I mean
because I have the platform because
Univision private sector they paid very
well I was on the air I was on the air
every day you know Monday through Friday
eight o'clock whether I wanted to or not
I went to work I went to work I have the
opportunity I grabbed the opportunity
and then after that I ran for congress
what where else do you think you could
do that here nowhere else in Cuba
Venezuela Nicaraguan Panama and
Dominicana and Argentina and Chile and
Uruguay Paraguay now only the United
States so how are you gonna come and
tell me that this is a bad country
really tell me where
this might be the easiest interview I've
ever done in my life because it's true
your passion and the reality of course
and I have nothing to do the
Constitution don't touch the United
States I'm not perfect of course it's
not perfect the system needs to be fixed
of course I know that there are some
grievances that we have to read address
some of the uh some of the minorities
some of the African Americans have not
had the opportunity that they deserve
when it comes to schooling when it comes
to housing I get it fix it and move on
and have a better Society not like oh
let's destroy this no what do you mean
destroy that's what Fidel said let's
destroy this because this system is
really bad look what they got
that's what my daughter I got nothing
else for you I guess all I can leave us
with is how about empirical evidence
Madura let me just tell you look
Venezuela Venezuela perfect example
I interviewed Travis in 2020. 2020 was
five minutes ago when it comes to the
grand scheme of things 2020 Chavez said
to me I'm going to implement Democratic
socialism and I go what really yeah
let's confiscate confiscate confiscate
Venezuela has the largest reserves of
oil in the world was the largest and the
most important the most robust economy
in Latin America largest reserves of oil
you know so then you have a lot to sell
they have wood they have minerals they
have water they have land they have
people right now the average Venezuelan
weighs 25 pounds 20 pounds less because
of lack of food
in Venezuela seven million seven million
Venezuelans have fled
what because Chavez wanted to implement
Democratic socialism and he said the
same thing I'm not going to do it like
Fidel did it no no I'm going to do it
the right way
and look there ain't no right way all
right I got two things for you sorry
that I you know but number one I want to
host you at the house we'll get some of
my Florida friends and we'll talk about
how great Florida is and uh what's your
favorite restaurant in Coral Gables how
about Lulu have you been to Lulu
yeah ah yes right there do you have a
brachi I've only been there and that's
an institution and you have another one
that it has been founded by a Colombian
who fled and his name and it's a liquor
something and it's right there and it's
a beautiful Tapas you eat some tapas and
you would drink some good wine so I will
treat you to that one and then you treat
me to uh an American one we don't really
need to be like this but we're gonna
high five all right thank you and thank
you for the opportunity let's hope the
average American understands what I'm
saying that's preserve the system
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell